good morning John in 2008 when we were
still in our first year of making
YouTube videos on the vlogbrothers
channel I decided that it would be funny
if I anagram the names of the
presidential candidates and now we are
nearly in 2012 and oh my goodness there
are more candidates and so I want to see
what mystery is the magic of anagram and
could tell us about this year's
Republican presidential hopeful let's
start out with the surprisingly
successful Ron Paul short names are nice
but often you don't get a lot of choice
but we've got a great one here our plan
which I like because a lot of the
members of the Occupy movement people
are like what's your plan well Ron Paul
is their plan Ron Paul our plan Rick
Perry it's really hard not to
immediately go to prick here but then
you kind of love to the meth and there's
not really much you can do with it
except a little bit of pirate slang yar
prick which I think it's pretty much
what any pirate would say if he saw the
advertisements that Rick Perry was
running in the Bible Belt Herman Cain I
know he's not technically hoping for
anything except for some good money
either think tanks are commentating on
Fox News but it's such a good anagram in
name I couldn't leave it alone now we
have canine harm and while you know
Herman Cain obviously not good at being
married I don't think he's a dog abuser
so let us instead go with inane charm
which I think pretty much encapsulate
his entire campaign Michele Bachmann I
couldn't find anything good here
unfortunately and I think that's
probably because I was focusing too hard
on finding something that had maniac in
it
Mitt Romney now not my merit would
probably be a pretty good one for MIT
but instead I think I'm gonna go with yo
mr. mitten because I've decided that I'm
calling him mr. mitten from now on Tim
Pawlenty he also dropped out early so
I'm gonna go ahead with latent wimpy
john huntsman and despite the fact that
he's behind a lot i wanted to include
him because he's pretty much my favorite
of the field but there aren't many good
anagrams but we do have john's math nun
and I'm good with John's math nun Rick
Santorum which anagrams amazingly enough
to Rick Santorum you don't have to do
anything to his name to make it funny
anymore Newt Gingrich was an interest
Challenge see immediately I saw that the
word right was in there and not long
after I found wing and I'm like right
wing is in Newt Gingrich's name that
seems very Tom Marvolo riddle to me and
we got these leftover letters I don't
know what to do with them until you put
in his middle name which is Lee Roy
surprise and what do you get
right-wing Cylon with some other letters
left over but right really I'll
genuinely freaked out and so there you
have it now we know we have our plan we
have mr. mitten we have a right wing
Cylon who do you rather vote for and
seen it's only thing I've had a
different poster there every day for
like a year so I walked it off all of my
posters for the project for awesome
raised a bunch of money but now what
we're going to do with those posters is
we're going to send them to the most
interesting comment now a lot of people
say just leave a comment and you'll
enter the contest I don't want to be
flooded with just people who are like I
want poster the most interesting comment
as judged by me will get the poster that
is on the wall for that video and I'll
course I'm gonna be looking for the
first 24 hours or so we'll send that
most interesting person a YouTube
message you send us your address we'll
send you the poster yay we get more
interesting comments you get a poster I
don't have to have them lying around my
office everybody wins
John think it's being great for drawing
Sharpie all over your face and charity
I'll see you on Friday hopefully by then
you will have the results of the project
for awesome voting and we will know
which charities are getting this you
chunk of money that all of us together
raised dftba
I just realized I spelled Rick Perry's
name wrong I don't care